they say that true love cannot speak
because it's expressed not in words but
actions this story is about a hacker in
love going by the name of wooter who
back in 2001 hacked Britney Spears
official website to prove that his love
was stronger than her security seriously
he wrote this in a love letter which he
posted on Britney's website alongside
the note Britney got hacked it turned
out that prior to the hack the guy had
actually warned the site's
administrators that the site was
vulnerable to attacks and asked them to
pay attention to the security holes
however they ignored him so he decided
to show his concern through action and
at the same time he took the opportunity
to confess his love for the idol you are
the best you probably heard that
millions of times but I mean it love you
at the end of the message the hacker
quite boldly left his phone number you
think Britney called him what was the
most unique Declaration of love you
received tell us in the comments don't
forget to subscribe and leave a heart